uh what does it take to be the guy or
gal who who uh who brings up the point
that this proxy might be outdated I
guess what does it take to have a
culture that enables that in the meeting
because that's a very uncomfortable
thing to bring up at a meeting we all
showed up here Friday this is such you
have just asked a million-dollar
question
so this is this isn't what you're if I
generalize what you're asking you
talking in general about truth telling
yeah and we humans are not really truth
seeking animals we are social animals
yeah we are and you know take you back
and time 10,000 years and you're in a
small
village if you go along to get along you
can survive you can procreate if you're
the village truth teller you might get
clubbed to death in the middle of the
night truths are often they don't want
to be heard cuz important truths can be
um uncomfortable they can be awkward
they can be exhausting impolite all that
kind of stuff challenging uh they can
make people defensive even if that's not
the intent but any High performing
organization whether it's a sports team
a business you know a political
organization an activist group I don't
care what it is any High performing
organization has to have mechanisms and
a culture that supports truth telling
one of the things you have to do is you
have to talk about that you have to talk
about the fact that it takes energy to
do that you have to talk to people you
have to remind people it's okay that
it's
uncomfortable um you to literally tell
people it's not what we're designed to
do as humans it's not really it's kind
of a side effect you know can do that
but it's not how we survive we mostly
Survive by being social animals um and
being cordial and cooperative and um
that's really important and so there's a
you know science is all about truth
telling it's actually a very formal
mechanism for trying to tell the truth
and even in science you find that it's
hard to tell the truth right H even you
know you're to have a hypothesis and
test it and find data and reject the
hypothesis and so on it's not easy but
even in science there's like the senior
scientists and the junior scientist and
then there's a hierarchy of humans where
the seniority somehow seniority matters
in the scientific process which is and
that's true inside companies too and so
you want to set up your culture so that
the most Junior
person can overrule the most senior
person if they have data um and and and
that really is about trying to you know
there are little things you can do so
for example in every meeting that I
attend I always speak
last and I know from
experience that you know if I speak
first even
very strong
willed um highly intelligent High
judgment participants in that meeting
will wonder well if Jeff thinks that I
came in this meeting thinking one thing
but maybe I'm not right and so you can
do little things like if you're the most
senior person in the
room go last let everybody else go first
in fact ideally try to have the most
jior person go first and the second then
try to go in order of
seniority um so that you can hear
everyone's opinion in a kind of
unfiltered way because we really do we
actually literally change our opinions
if somebody who you really respect says
something makes you change your mind a
little so you're saying implicitly or
explicitly give permission for people to
have a strong opinion that as long as
it's backed by data yes and sometimes it
can even by the way a lot of our most
powerful truths turn out to be hunches
they turn out to be based on anecdotes
their intuition based and sometimes you
don't even have strong data but you may
know you may know the person well enough
to trust their judgment you may feel
yourself leaning in it may resonate with
a set of anecdotes you have and then you
may be able to say you know I I
something about that feels right let's
go collect some data on that let's try
to see if we can actually know whether
it's right but for now let's not
disregard it because it feels right you
can also fight inherent bias there's an
optimism bias like if there are two
interpretations of a new set of data and
one of them is happy and one of them is
unhappy it's a little dangerous to jump
to the conclusion that the happy
interpretation is right you may want to
sort of compensate for that human bias
of of looking for you know trying to
find the Silver Lining and said look
this that might be good but I'm going to
go with it's bad for now until we're
sure